herzlich willkommen in susan
sideropoulos sagen sie sie haben an
diesem projekt mitgewirkt warum war es
ihnen so wichtig dabei zu sein
hallo ja ich freue mich auf jeden fall
sehr ein teil dieses großartige projekt
zu sein
ich bin grundsätzlich schon sehr
wählerisch und gucke mir alle sachen und
alle anfragen ganz genau an weil man mag
es kaum glauben ich bin schon sehr viele
jahre in öffentlichkeit 20 jahre und
auch eigentlich sehr offen mit meinen
herkunft meiner multikulti familie und
muss tatsächlich zugeben dass ich
persönlich keine antisemitischen
erfahrungen gemacht habe
toi toi toi woran das jetzt liegt
darüber könnte man jetzt noch mal eine
ganze weile sprechen
allerdings weiß ich natürlich aus meinem
umfeld aus meinem freundeskreis viele
viele geschichten und ich fand dieses
projekt besonders toll weil das nochmal
neuen ansatz hat da sind junge menschen
zusammengekommen
die neue ideen haben und im prinzip ja
auch für ihre also die sind ja wie
selber ihre eigene zielgruppe
man möchte die neue generation
ansprechen und schaut einfach wie kann
man das macht der marke du hast dieses
projekt mitentwickelt berichtet uns ein
bisschen darüber wie die idee entstanden
ist und was ihr mit diesem projekt er
bezwecken wollte wie nie erreichen wollt
was es verändern kann
wir sind relativ schnell darauf gekommen
dass es nicht um die fälle gehen soll
die ja ohnehin und gott sei dank auch
schon in der berichterstattung sehr viel
auftauchen sondern wir wollten uns auf
das bewusst kleine auf das alltägliche
konzentrieren auf die situation wohl
niemand sagen kann dass das nicht in
seiner umgebung oder in seinem umfeld
stattfindet sondern das eben was im
freundeskreis auf der arbeit in der
schule beim sport wo auch immer
stattfindet und diese geschichten haben
wir dann mit jüdinnen und juden aus ganz
deutschland zusammen getragen da hatten
wir erst mal über 35 das konnten wir
leider auf grund der zeit die wir zur
verfügung hatten nicht alle umsetzen
aber wir haben uns dann für sechs
entschieden um eine möglichst breite
auswahl abzubilden frau sie der
europolis sie hatten eingangs gesagt sie
müssten jetzt selbst noch kein
antisemitismus in ihrem alltag erleben
was können wir aber alles tun um
antisemitismus zu bekämpfen
ich finde es
also nicht wichtig dass wir offen
bleiben dass wir neugierig sind dass man
fragen stellt ich glaube dass auch
deshalb mir das erspart geblieben ist
weil ich ein sehr selbst sehr offen bin
sehr neugierig und immer so eine kleine
tür aufmache auch bei social media und
einfach zeige so sieht ein ganz normales
jüdisches leben aus das ist gar nicht
gar nicht viel anders wir vermitteln
einfach werte wir sind traditionell und
ich finde es ganz toll ich bin zum
beispiel botschafterin bei german dream
das ist der verein von losen tee kann
unter anderem und die gehen an schulen
die erzählen geschichten und ich finde
dass das ist gut ich glaube wir müssen
wahnsinnig viel im gespräch bleiben und
gar nicht partout immer sagen in solchen
situationen nein das sagt man nicht und
hör auf sondern auch mal fragen warum
sagst du das jetzt wie kommst du darauf
was ist denn dein antrieb so eine
aussage zu treffen und ich glaube da
kommt man viel weiter wenn man ja offen
bleibt für ein gespräch wie stärken wir
wir wissen ja dass so was manchmal ganz
ganz schwer ist dann den mund
aufzumachen gerade wenn man alleine in
berlin unterwegs ist und den
antisemitismus mitbekommt oder er fährt
wie stärkt man da den mut in solchen
situationen eben nicht still zu halten
und den mund aufzumachen einzuschreiten
ja das ist natürlich das thema
zivilcourage je nachdem wie aggressiv
ein moment natürlich aussieht bin ich da
auch gespalten sage ich jetzt mal ich
finde es wahnsinnig wichtig einzugreifen
und aber man muss natürlich auch
vorsichtig sein aber wenn eine ganz
normale unter sprechen wir ja eben auch
von ganz normalen situationen ich finde
das ist wie man sitzt in der großen
gruppe und an velten spruch und
antisemitismus es eben keine meinung ich
meine das ist nicht so wie ich mal gelb
und du machst grün und ich fahre gerne
dort in urlaub und du dahin sondern es
ist eine grundlegende sache die einfach
die man so nicht stehen lassen kann und
ich finde da ist es durchaus angebracht
von der seite auch mal zu sagen dass das
geht nicht oder beziehungsweise eben
nach zu fragen wieso sagt so dass jetzt
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren